[Musica]
Buongiorno a tutti Non preoccupatevi non
parlerò in tedesco oggi e tantomeno non
è tedesco quello il saluto che vi ho
proposto ma è nel Cimbro di Giazza il
cosiddetto touch e proprio oggi
parleremo di questa lingua antica una
lingua medievale parlata ancora sui
nostri Monti una lingua arrivata qui nel
Medioevo
dobbiamo pensare che i Cimbri Oggi
giorno diffusi soltanto nei territori
qui in Violetto nella cartina quindi a
Mezza Selva di Roana nell'altopiano di
Sette Comuni a Luserna in Trentino e
nella frazione di Giazza a Selva di
Progno qui in provincia di Verona sono i
discendenti di coloni bavaresi alle mani
che nel corso del Medioevo a partire
dall'anno 1100 poi fino al 1300 hanno
colonizzato questi territori impervi
delle nostre montagne perché chiamati da
Vescovi a disboscare a far carbone e
allevare coltivare questi territori
molto disabitati e impervi per l'appunto
Dobbiamo immaginare che questo
territorio un tempo della montagna
Veneta la montagna Trentina era abitata
da 20.000 persone parlanti questi idioma
nel 1600 Infatti all'apice della parlata
cimbra c'erano così tante persone a
parlare questa Antica parlata tra i del
Trentino e del Veneto moderni
Però alcuni studiosi tra cui Bruno
schweitzer tra gli anni 30 e 40 Il più
grande studioso della lingua cimbra che
qui negli anni nel Novecento fa queste
sue ricerche sul campo a Giazza e Sette
Comuni trova alcuni elementi che fanno
presumere però che prima ancora
dell'arrivo di questi coloni bavaresi
fossero già presenti popolazioni
germaniche come i Longobardi gli animali
che hanno facilitato un mescolamento di
queste popolazioni da un bar da una
parte bavaresi e dall'altra il
Longobardi Questa teoria però non è la
più accettata nella comunità scientifica
e si presume infatti che solamente
queste popolazioni bavaresi abbiano in
qualche modo trasmesso ai parlanti
attuali la loro lingua
molte volte si sente parlare del cibo
come un relitto del passato una lingua
medievale per un tedesco moderno si
sente dire che ascoltare un Cimbro è
come per noi italiani ascoltare un
parlare un po' Dante
Questo fatto non è totalmente vero
perché una lingua deve essere vista come
un organismo vivo che cambia si evolve
nel corso dei secoli e pertanto il
Cimbro parlato tutt'oggi non è più
quella lingua medievale arrivata qui i
secoli fa Tuttavia mantiene di caratteri
medievali molto antichi che il tedesco
ha perso
D'altro canto Il tedesco a differenza
del Cimbro mantiene altri fenomeni che
il Cimbro ha perso a causa del contatti
con le popolazioni italiane con i
dialetti veneti e non solo tirando
mutato la lingua nel corso dei secoli A
tal proposito il professore Ermenegildo
bidese dell'università di Trento scrive
l'influsso della vicina lingua italiana
da secoli usata accanto al proprio
idioma Era troppo potente per non far sì
che questo piccolo popolo non dovesse
abituarsi in qualche modo a pensare in
italiano e a disporre e a collegare le
proprie parole quantunque tedesche alla
maniera italiana e adesso vedremo
brevemente Quali sono le parlate i
dialetti che hanno modificato negli anni
questa Antica parlata il Cimbro il touch
ci verrebbe da pensare correttamente
anche che sono stati i dialetti veneti a
modificare il Cimbro però non sono
soltanto stati i dialetti veneti Infatti
Bruno schweitzer questo grandissimo
studioso della lingua cimbra scrive
nella sua grammatica un elenco di parole
qui riportate
pirun la forchetta botun il bottone e
così via Queste sono parole che ancora
oggi gli ultimi parlanti di Giazza
utilizzano nella loro parlata cimbra in
questo antico idioma ma queste parole
non sono Germani che sono parole che
naturalmente un Veneto qualsiasi persona
di noi che parli un dialetto veneto
comprende facilmente però cosa
presentano una u alquanto strana Non è
una Veneta
Bruno schweitzer definisce questa u la u
del Lombardo orientale quindi in qualche
modo i Cimbri hanno avuto un contatto
con popolazioni Lombarde Ma come è
possibile i nostri territori non sono
abitati da popolazioni aventi un
dialetto lombardo
dobbiamo pensare che un tempo i dialetti
Lombardi diffusi ancora oggi in Trentino
erano molto più spostati verso il Veneto
quindi nelle Prealpi Venete c'è stato
questo contatto tra popolazione italiane
parlanti un dialetto lombardo e questi
antichi Cimbri che poi hanno mantenuto
nei secoli queste parole Lombarde ancora
presenti per esempio nel Bergamasco
e proprio Grazie Cimbri riusciamo a
capire come fossero disposte le parlate
italiane secoli fa grazie al Cimbro
un'altra parlata che ha modificato nei
secoli il Cimbro è stato il latino cos'è
il latino quindi la cartina vediamo Il
ladino indicato con un colore blu tra le
province di Trento Bolzano e Belluno
dobbiamo pensare che un tempo i Ladini
questa popolazione che parla una lingua
neolatina Quindi come l'italiano che
deriva dal latino
fossero diffusi molto più a sud Rispetto
ad oggi quindi verso anche Luserna in
Sette Comuni c'erano popolazioni nel
lato Trentino parlanti questa lingua
iladino questi Ladini che vivono molto
più a sud e che col tempo sono stati
mandati verso nord per la venetizzazione
del territorio e verso sud per la
germanizzazione dell'Alto Adige hanno in
qualche modo un tempo modificato la
lingua singolarmente stranamente i
Cimbri hanno avuto il contatto anche con
questo popolo dove lo Notiamo in alcune
parole che answer un linguista bavarese
identifica come una trasformazione della
u della o Inu quindi nuovamente questo
fenomeno che potrebbe essere sia
Lombardo che la Dino viene ritrovato
anche da antiroller soprattutto in
quelle parole in cui è presente una
consonante nasale ossia dove quando il
suono l'aria prodotta dai polmoni
fuoriesce dal naso e non della Zucca
quindi la n e la n Ad esempio in
bavarese ma anche nel Cimbro dei Sette
Comuni quindi di Asiago per capirci la
casa si dirà oam come in inglese Home
Home Sweet Home per capirci
soltanto che per questo influsso Lavino
la o diventa una u quindi casa a Giazza
ma anche a Luserna verrà pronunciato Uam
Alfonso Bellotto ulteriore linguista
Noto un altro carattere ladino in queste
lingue germaniche la i lunga tedesca
come nella parola Yar l'anno nelle
parlate di Giazza e di Luserna diventa
Jar nuovamente per l'influsso ladino
Quindi grazie a queste lingue
che hanno cambiato il Cimbro capiamo
come fossero posizionate le popolazioni
italiane ancora secoli fa
per l'appunto parlavamo del Cimbro di
Giazza il Cimbro Veronese che si
conserva solamente a jazz Ma che un
tempo era parlato in tutti i 13 comuni
della Lessinia questo Cimbro della
Lessinia presenta questi caratteri
romanzi questi caratteri non prettamente
germanici perché dovuti alle parlate di
dialetti che hanno cambiato questa
antica lingua bavarese
però la particolarità di Giazza che
mantiene sia una pronuncia nuova sia una
pronuncia più antica la pronuncia più
antica è ad esempio nella parola anno
che viene pronunciata Yar come in
tedesco oppure giar con la pronuncia
dovuta al contatto con i latini quindi
un carattere molto ibrido del Cimbro di
Giazza dobbiamo pensare però che questo
scambio linguistico non deve essere
visto come uno scambio unidirezionale
perché anche il Cimbro si ha cambiato i
dialetti veneti ma anche i dialetti
veneti di questi territori sono stati in
qualche modo Cambiati influenzati dal
cibo o meglio nei territori dove un
tempo si parlava il Cimbro e che dove
ora si parla il Veneto
vengono mantenute alcune parole antiche
parole per l'appunto cimbra Dove
troviamo questi nomi Cimbri nella
toponomastica nei nomi del territorio se
andiamo su a Rovere Veronese troveremo
per esempio la contrada Jaeger la
contrada Cacciatore dal Cimbro Jaeger
corrispettivo anche del tedesco Jaeger
Lo troveremo tante reche Light
In questi territori dove un tempo si
parlava questa antica lingua tedesca
un altro un'altra classe di parole
presentanti un carattere antico
Germanico sono i cognomi di queste zone
molti cognomi non sono più riconoscibili
come Cimbri perché negli anni sono stati
romanizzati però Esistono i cognomi la
cui origine chiaramente cimbra ossia
tutti quei cognomi aventi l'accento
sulla prima sillaba e terminanti in le
questioni sono per esempio ster che le
rape le somme le zoom le zecchele e
Mosele per esempio il primo sterkele
deriva dal Cimbro Stars forte a cui
viene aggiunta la desinenza di
diminutivo quindi piccolo perché vuol
dire piccolo forte
altri termini si mantengono nella lingua
parlata di questi territori vi riporto
alcuni termini diffusi soprattutto Bosco
Chiesanuova
il rospo viene chiamato con il termine
crota derivante per l'appunto dal Cimbro
crote corrispettivo del tedesco moderno
Gretel rospo per l'appunto abbiamo poi
un termine Un po' simpatico che è
feffarlo che per denominare i grani di
pepe anche nei salumi che deriva per
l'appunto dal Cimbro fefar Pepe a cui
viene aggiunta la desinenza alle piccolo
quindi piccolo Pepe un grano di Pepe
abbiamo poi pummerlo è un termine
utilizzato a Bosco Chiesanuova per
definire il meticcio il cagnetto
volgarmente chiamato Il bastardino e
deriva da una parola ancora usata nei
dialetti alle mani pumar che significa
cane humarlo Puma piccolo cane
Infine un termine utilizzato anche al di
fuori della reale Cimbro nel veronese
che va a definire un dolce tipico del
carnevale conosciuto in altri luoghi del
Veneto come crostoli o crostoli in
italiano Chiacchiero galani e sono nella
reale Cimbro le sossole questo termine
probabilmente deriva nuovamente dal
Cimbro quale parola deriva
dall'aggettivo o anche nome
suas dolce con l'aggiunta nuovamente di
questa desinenza le piccolo quindi
piccolo dolce originariamente avevamo
zuisley col tempo corrotto negli anni
sossole
quindi dobbiamo ricordarci che il Cimbro
non deve essere dimenticato
assolutamente perché parte delle nostre
comunità della montagna è parte delle
nostre radici e per questo deve essere
in qualche modo mantenuto non come
lingua parlata naturalmente Ma come
lingua del ricordo lingua di corto di
cultura e per questo vi ringrazio
salutandovi ancora in Cimbro Arrivederci
Varzi Grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]